everybody welcome to another Python 3
tutorial video and also at the beginning
of a bit of a mini series format plot
lib if you want to know even more about
matplotlib after this series I would
just say I've got a very extensive
matplotlib series on my channel it is in
Python 2.7 but aside from print
functions and then also the difference
between try and accept the code should
be completely portable over to Python 3
my goal here is just to show you guys
some quick basics for matplotlib and
then move on but if you want to know
more about customization maybe fancy
graphing and charting and all that
definitely check out that other series
but here I'm just going to show you a
lot of the basics now matplotlib is not
a part of your standard library we'll
have to download it it is a third-party
module luckily for everyone this should
be very simple to download but I suppose
if you're on Linux or something like
that it might be a little more tedious
but actually downloading modules on
Linux is very simple downloading them on
site windows is very challenging
sometimes but luckily I'll show you guys
here that it is not too bad so let's go
ahead and get started the first thing I
want to show you guys is first of all
the website is matplotlib
org is the official web site for this
you can't come down and go to the
matplotlib downloads page and you can
actually you'll find that there are
executable downloadable files for you to
install matplotlib on your system now
we're actually running on Python 3.4 and
for whatever reason they have not
updated map Polidori to include Python
3.4 and last I checked you actually came
and run three because it's going to look
for you know c-clone slash Python 33 not
34 so that won't even really work but
you could come here also and download
the source you setup dot exe or just
yourself move the files but that's
obviously somewhat of a challenge for
some people so we're not going to do
that instead we're going to come over
here to this websites this I'll put the
link in the description if I forget
someone remind me I've been pretty good
lately about remembering to put the
links in the descriptions but I
like to forget sometimes so come over
here and this website I highly suggest
you just bookmark this website anytime
you want to install something for Python
especially if you're a 64-bit Python
user you'll find that a lot of times you
can't get 64-bit versions of modules
inherently but what this guy does is he
maintains his page and adds dot exe
installers for 32-bit and 64-bit and
also as you'll see he's even updated
some of them to include the proper
version or the current version so for
example we can go find and search for
matplotlib and here it is so we can
click on that and it comes down here and
we're at the matplotlib now as you can
see there's a ton of stuff here what I'm
interested in what you're interested in
most likely at least if you're watching
this video right now is going to be
either this one right here for 64-bit or
you can come down here for the 32-bit
actually this is what you would write
here for 32-bit now I already have it
installed so I'm not going to read
install it but take note up here all the
things that are required or it's s
requires I think it really means like if
you want to use every part of matplotlib
you need all these things I just suggest
you download numpy for sure date util PI
TZ PI parsing 6 and then ok they do say
off foot-in-mouth um yeah you should be
able to just not download any of these
there I don't see any reason why you
would need these at least for now
so anyway download you know just just
hold down ctrl click on you know the
version of matplotlib then click on day
2 pi gz parsing 6 and then you should be
brought to each of those right because
of the way that we click them download
those install those you'll be ready to
go someone sure so do that pause the
video now while you're installing it if
you don't have it and then pick back up
so I'm done with that now let's go ahead
um assuming you've got everything
installed we're ready to actually begin
so first we need to import matplotlib
now generally for just basic plotting we
use what's called PI plot in matte flat
lip so really you want to do something
do the
so go to the top from that plot live
import pie plot and you could stop here
but most people will import pie plot as
PLT so you'll be seeing a lot of example
code probably if you're ever looking up
how to do something you'll see people
use PLT that's why same thing with like
numpy people use NP it's just what
people do now um the next thing that we
would want to do is peel T it up a lot
and then in here you can you plot X's
and you plot wise so you could just plot
a simple you know 5 7 so 5 X 7 is why
but let's actually make lists out of
this so we plot X as a list 5 6 7 8
let's say and then Y is a list 7 3 8 3
okay so what this does is it generates
this plot and it will draw them on to
this plot for you but you won't see
anything if this is all you do you have
to always end with the PLT show and
later on you might get the idea that you
want to make live graphs or graphs that
update it's important to understand how
this actually works because plot just
kind of puts it up there and then
actually I use the wrong word but you've
got draw which actually draws it onto
the figure and then you have to reshow
to actually update the figures so just
keep that in mind for way later down the
road but just understand that this
plotting it does not actually make the
graph show up it just kind of stores it
to memory what it ought to look like and
then plot that show brings it up so with
that let's go ahead and save and run it
and up pops the following graph so as
you can see we've made a whole lot of
progress in very short time we've got a
nice window here so you've been through
the tkinter tutorial so you can maybe
appreciate what we have going on here so
we've got this figure and I could be
wrong but I'm almost certain that
matplotlib is actually generated all
with tkinter so a lot of people ask ask
me to do a tutorial on how to put
matplotlib into tkinter and
and sometimes I just want to respond I
look at the documents for map let live
so it's exactly what map if it's going
anyway so because like these are buttons
you know these are buttons that are
added in by a tea cancer and all that so
anyway moving on so we've got a chart I
guess it would be kind of helpful to run
through all these options real quickly
for you guys so the first one is home
now I can't really show you much about
home because we haven't done anything
but it will reset your view to the
original view that you were looking and
in fact let me bring this over like this
at least
so that's home then you've got the
forwarding back so I guess the first
thing we should do let's zoom in first
to get a feel for everything so this is
a zoom so you get this little button and
you can click and drag and you basically
use ohm into that spot so then home verb
is set back to where you you know the
original view so let's zoom in one more
time and then you have these buttons
here which is forward and back so let's
do them in one more time and we're like
oh man it's too close we're not seeing
anything so you hit the back arrow and
you go back a little bit but let's say
you miss clicked and you went back twice
darn it you want to go back forward
again so you can click the forward arrow
and get back again this one is just so
you can kind of like click and drag and
pull this thing around it looks better
privateering home but you can see that
you can just click and move it around
um and then finally well obviously this
is just to save the figure it's gonna by
nature oh this one saves as PNG
um I think Norah and Python 2 7 the
default is like this tiff and it's
really annoying
but looks like they've figured it out
now it's by default PNG anyway that's
how you can save the figure that you're
looking at to like an image file or
actually they have a quite a few
different file types
finally configure subplots you probably
will stop using this and you'll actually
be coding it into your script but it's
helpful to know this is just distance
right on the side so left how much
distance on the left do we want to allow
for how much distance I'm with is up how
much distance on the bottom do we want
to allow for right top and then W space
in H space you're not gonna be able to
see that right now it's when you have
multiple figures or multiple plots on
the same figure
so here is your figure right and then
this is a apply basically and if you
have multiple plots it's a subplot so
this will be you know the space on the
sides of all the plots and then this
will be the space on the top of all the
plots again you probably won't find
yourself using this too much besides
just for testing so if you generate a
plot with say 15 figure or 15 plots on
it um you might get it like watch your
mouth when you're like talking about mat
flat live and a lot of coding stuff man
because you want to use specific terms
and it's not you think of a figure like
in textbooks they always refer to like
each little thing as a figure but here a
figure is the entire window and then
you've got the plots within it anyway
keep wanting to call them figures so I'm
trying to trying to be careful but
anyway we have multiple subplots on
there you might use this to be like okay
well I want a hard code it to always be
left you know point zero six bottom
whatever and so on so you'll use it
maybe there but eventually you'll start
like hard coding in these values because
you can set it in your script what you
want these values to be they just happen
to have a default so anyway that
concludes the intro to matplotlib
there's a lot more to do in this this
little mini series again there is even
way more that you can do then what I'll
cover here but get you guys at least
started on matte pot lid so anyway
that's going to conclude this video stay
tuned for the next video for a
continuation from that plot lib if you
guys have any questions or comments on
these three lines of very complex code
feel free to leave them below as always
thanks for watching thanks for all the
support and subscriptions and until next
time